welcome to this video playing the chess
Pro King yeah he's a chess Pro and a
king that's quite a lot okay so hmm
I want to get to some three-door type of
position
now we got to an old Indian
maybe I get in Bishop G5 oh he's not
really trying to prevent that
okay
so I can trade now maybe I should shoot
trade
ticks with the queen okay
yeah okay maybe just just canceling
short we'll do
and then go go from there okay so he
wants to do something here on the king
side Maybe
yeah move like Queen F6 to prepare
Knight F4 is uh
not on
he can always go Knight B5
hmm
G4 is kind of annoying
this happens
I mean it's not not like the end of the
world but
not not really great
now on Knight B5 I have Knight A6 which
is well not great but at least
playable
okay pushing pushing this back
okay
quite sure where he wants to go with
that but he can do that it's not like
bad but
here after a possible capture no it's
not keep capturing it's advancing okay
so he just closes the queen side
okay it's playing really quickly that's
uh
definitely the case and
and take now G6 G4 that's not really
that great
okay I can play F6 all the time so
not in trouble maybe
it's not not brilliant but also not not
that bad
I can always play F6 to get some ground
on the king side
the whole situation is very um
dependent or it's very clear that it's
important that the queen side is closed
if we could open the queen side somehow
which he cannot
then this would be
a real problem for black
but I don't really see any
anything great that you can do them
yeah now I possibly threatened H5
with the good
a good term change of structure
okay
um H5 or maybe I should start with this
foreign
or not
no let's
prepare that with Rook F7 Rook f8
um Bishop G4 this is possible
it's not crazy but also not necessary I
can
can prepare it at all a little bit more
and now H5 G5 Knight H7 is is really bad
and um
capturing also leads to a good position
for black
I think at least
Knight takes nine takes and I will get a
knight F4 this pressure only two is
rather annoying
for him
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but the thing
is
I mean I can't take but this is probably
not not enough right
hmm there's some way to
yeah maybe this and then
Pawn takes and invading check I mean
King G7 of course first
uh ah this this I can do this first okay
this is nice now I can get the king to
E5
okay first The Rook
wow
this is not winning for black
I cannot really believe it
with like just two completely invading
here
Bishop F1 H3 or something I don't know I
can just remove the bishop if I want
six
yeah I can I can also just take
everything
I think
take C4
and the C Pawn should should do the job
C3 King it's just promoting
and it's it's with check all the time
check check
white forfeits due to disconnection okay
yeah yeah we know the we know the ammo
yeah I don't know I mean it's it's
simply I mean it looks maybe nice for
white at first because of his space but
it's really
really nothing going on oh that's a
funny misjudgment yeah
stockfish gives a wide a large Advantage
here which is which is really funny
because especially it gives why the last
large Advantage after this and this is
just a total joke because how is black
ever going to lose the position I mean I
just can stay and do nothing and why it
can absolutely do nothing
but the only one who can take I mean I
have an idea with H5 well white has no
idea the only idea that wise has okay
it's Knight A4 and sacrifice on B6 but
that's never going to happen
so uh this is a very typical case where
the computer is not understanding the
position yeah yeah there will be people
posting how can you say that blah blah
blah but white is um simply not better
here
and that's simply not the case
I mean or is there something concrete
terrible happening to me I don't I don't
really see it
F4 maybe you can play F4 at some point
but I mean I can probably
I can probably even play G5 and never
lose
that's debatable however
I'm kind of curious now
so this this kind of thing
um
it would be nice to get in age five
really
can I start with this
computer wants to play Rook H4 let me
just put out some moves I'm really
curious
if um the engine
is having some
some great thing up his up up its sleeve
because it really looks like like a
fortress
maybe here this is a line that the
computer is giving
and still 1.2 for white which is
kinda hard to believe
yeah I know it is not very active for
black but but how are you going to win
here
with one king G8
look hh1 I'm just putting out some moves
by the comp
the advantage is getting bigger and
bigger in the comms evaluation
RK Knight H4 yeah okay okay okay
yeah F4 is coming okay yeah maybe maybe
this is the problem that F4 is coming
and the unfavorable circumstances
so I maybe shouldn't play H5 but
I can prepare this
and again therefore yeah maybe I'm I
miss I'm not evaluating it correctly
it's possible
it's possible it looks like some some
sort of Fortress but
I already didn't think that white is any
better
or should I play really this G5 business
yeah if I do something like that Rook
here
I probably have now there's this piece
configuration is not good the Knight is
somewhere else then then this might be
might be an idea
so what maybe I should just double here
double on the
double on the on the f file now this is
maybe the right way to do it because F4
is the is the break that is probably
coming yeah this is what I need to do
yeah okay
something like that now here
then and then and then and then yeah I
can I can just Shuffle really
there's really no way forward here right
I mean something
remotely active
yeah the computer also doesn't have any
idea it Shuffles
yeah this is what makes it equal yeah
okay I was too optimistic that I thought
that maybe black can even do something
with H5 but
um it is probably just um just equal
the computer is on 1.3 which which I
mean
he it doesn't it won't find a way
forward here I think
as I have to double on there far that's
important so that F4 is not hitting me
and then I'm okay and I shouldn't play
H5 I should just stay as it is if he
goes a G5 at some point let's say like
this oops
I will gladly jump here and uh possibly
to F4 so this is not coming and F4i is
not really possible I'm always on those
Pawns
and this is also why I shouldn't play H5
G5 and then F4 because I want this G4
Pawn to attack yeah okay this is the
equal this is what makes the position
still okay for black yeah it's it's just
I can just Shuffle and and make it equal
um if you look at the computer line here
by stockfish the display is 14 14 moves
D but it's just shuffling around without
any any idea
okay sorry for this longer I'm always
fascinated by by some some computer
evaluations I understand that the engine
is fantastic yeah in in most cases but
they tend to
um wrongly evaluate those kind of closed
Kings Indian type of position very often
so I'm always interested in checking
this okay sorry for the very long
examination here at the end thanks for
watching